apologies chairman we're live now
okay thank you right good evening
members and anyone visiting us on the
youtube stream this evening uh the
development committee
25th of february 2021
item one is apologies for absence
they've been received from councillor
iano and item two substitute members we
have councillor wilkinson
who's providing that substitute item
three
non-members attending a welcome council
award and
council ahoy item four
minutes of the meeting held on the 10th
of december
2020 are you happy for those to be
authorized in due course
uh i will assume that uh that's okay
unless i see a blue hand indicating
no indication thank you very much item
five to receive declarations of interest
you just indicate if you've got anything
you wish to declare
there on on that's great thank you very
much and we move
swiftly on to item six
land to the north of london road
west roarworth industrial estate raleigh
and
katy rogers is going to present to us on
this one please
thank you chairman i'm just going to
share my screen
hopefully you can see the plan on screen
please indicate you can't
this application seeks reserve matters
approval
in relation to a proposed bridge at the
strategic residential development site
known as woolsey park
which is to the west of raleigh the
wider site
extends from rorus lane to the north
indicated by my cursor here
down to london road to the south
outline planning permission was approved
in 2015
and the parameter plan on screen is that
approved relating to the outline
planning consent
this envisaged a spine road which is
this is grey
weaving through the site which would run
the length of the site
and cross the rorus brook in this
position approximately centrally in the
screen indicated by my cursor
so the plan on screen now shows two
sections of the spine road that um
have been most recently approved or the
sections have already
also received reserve matters consent
um and these are the sections
immediately north and
south of the rorith brook
these already um benefit from reserve
mata's consent
and the proposal tonight is for the
bridge which would link these two
sections
indicated by my cursor here
so the red line application site
relating to the current application
is therefore limited to a small
rectangle shown on screen
the brook is the line running from the
top
left and to the bottom right of the
screen
and the proposed bridge is denoted by
the two parallel lines
in the center
so the plan on screen shows the proposed
bridge and the landscaping around it
and this plan shows the bridge with a
footway um
on the northern side which would link to
the footway it would run
alongside the already approved fully
approved section of bridge
um to the north and again to the south
and then on the south side of the bridge
you would have a section of footweight
and cycleway so a slightly wider
sort of pedestrian area and that would
also link to the other sections
of approved road already
so this plan shows just slightly zoomed
in
um to two of the sections that have been
provided so firstly if we look on the
left hand side of the screen to section
a a
um this shows um the highway the road
um at a slight angle um and then the
wider
uh pedestrian cycleway to one side of
the
carriageway and the narrower pedestrian
only
to the other side and you'll see the
upright
highway barriers that are proposed to
either side one slightly higher than the
other
on the elevation plan then in the middle
of the screen which is labeled bb
you'll see obviously in elevation uh the
railing that's proposed
along the stretch of the bridge
elevation bb also shows in this dotted
line
which is indicated by my cursor here
just slowly going down
the existing ground level and the
profile of the river that the bridge
will cross
the applicant has provided um
some visuals to help members these would
not be approved plans but
they are intended to help members sort
of visualize
what that elevation would look like um
in the context
of the um profile of the existing river
bank and land around so the first of
these visuals is on screen and shows the
bridge proposed shows that the bridge
proposed
is a flat design of a low profile rather
than a humped design
with the road over the bridge at the
same level as the sections of road to
the north and south
they're the sections that already
benefit from from reserve matters
consent
um and the the section of carriageway
and the pedestrian
um and cycleweights either side would
not be raised to any significant degree
in relation to these other sections of
the spine road
but just then flick through this um
these visuals so we've had a number of
visuals provided but let's just
move that so again this is just viewed
from the other angle
so the bridge would be a concrete
precast concrete structure
um and part of it would be to follow the
profile of the existing riverbank
um this image does not have the
um highway um railing shown so that that
would
be a top of of that and precast wall
and so that's from the other angle these
are the elevation
so two elevation images they're pretty
similar to the elevations
but without the engineering aspect of
that
on those and then this one just shows
some of the engineering detail that's
provided on the elevation plan
is for approval and it just shows the
underground elements of the bridge
but it would be um the bits of the
bridge in
image one that would project above
um the proposed ground level
so the proposed bridge design is
functional and would
um complete the original intended spine
road that would run through the
development
site the highway authority raised no
objection and neither did the
environment agency
and the recommendation therefore is one
of approval subject to the conditions
in the committee report thank you thank
you
if you could just knock your screen off
share please
thank you thank you members to my mind
this is a reasonably
straightforward application i believe
all of the details
around this bridge are already consented
the bridge would have been part of a
a previous consent but it was just held
up for one or two technical engineering
details
um counselor stanley you just want to
have a quick comment on this one
before we move um can't stop quite thank
you chairman
um just to ask um do we actually
know what the height of the bridge is
from the underside
to the stream
i would say that's a bit of a challenge
depends how much water is in the stream
oh no at the moment at the moment
as it stands at the moment where the
bridge is going to go in
what is the height of the bridge to the
the height of this of the uh the ditch
or the stream or wherever it is that
what i'm getting at is that if there
isn't is it isn't sufficient height
we could find uh the the the underneath
the bridge could be
damned and the water will collect and go
over the top
of the breach we'll cur we'll gather
upon the questions but
on the plan katie showed us
it did show the one in a hundred one in
a hundred year
flood position uh councillor hawkway you
have a question i'm not talking about
one in a hundred year flooding another
council stanley if we could just move on
well you've got
you give me the wrong answer you give me
the wrong answer
councillor hawkway
uh yes chairman um yeah my question was
related because it's um
a sort of a flat low level bridge is
that um
um there's no uh
there's no uh in consideration
that uh flooding is a major risk in
relation to the bridge or
adjacent uh area
i didn't know this yeah yes but
in the in the description we've had
already the environment agency have
clearly stated that they
they don't object to this um katie would
you just like to answer those questions
please
yeah okay so maybe if i share my screen
again
sorry
okay so let's go back to so if we go
back to the original outline planning
consent so
at the outline stage um flooding
um in relation to all aspects of the pro
development was considered so
this the the bridge proposal already
benefits from outline planning
commission
so in principle a crossing here is
acceptable
um but what the environment agency we're
keen to to
interrogate is the detailed design um
and so that's obviously why there's been
a delay
in this application this section of the
spine mode coming forward
um it's why we've had other sections
already granted reserve matters approval
and this is the last element because the
detailed design is
is key it's it bridges um a main river
and the environment agency you know
wanted to scrutinize
that design so they have done so in the
application submission
and the applicant submitted an uh a copy
of the
the permit that they've applied for to
the ea
um and if i and the ea
are comfortable with the design so
they're satisfied that in flood risk
terms
this bridge design to the um dimensions
the heights above the um the riverbed
and
the the flood um the modeled flood
levels
is appropriate here so yeah they're the
specialist consultant and they they say
that this design
is fine in that regard um what i i could
always
take you to to councillor stanley's
sorry this this plan
so to counselor stanley um's question
i can maybe just zoom into this section
here a little bit more
um so what you can see is this dashed
line
is the existing ground level so the
profile of the riverbed
and what i don't have because i can't
readily
using a pdf i can't get a measurement
from the from the
from the base of the river to to the top
of the or the underside of the
concrete structure of the bridge but
what it has got is this dimension of a
90 um um 90 centimeters here
and that is the requirement that the ea
were concerned about and that's what
this bridge design meets so
there's always going to be that
clearance from this
100 flood level and that specifically is
what the ea required and so
they tell us that this design is safe in
terms of flood risk
thank you
all right members we have a
recommendation
for approval printed on 6.1
and 6.2
so can i first ask if there are any
members
okay i'll just check out everyone has
been able to
hear the discussion no one's had any
technical issues
that's good so if we move to the vote
then please
does any member wish to have a recorded
vote
please indicate with your hand if you do
so
okay you wouldn't mind dropping your
hand cancer stanley so there won't be a
recorded vote
thank you can i ask those members in
favor of the application to please
indicate
i can't seem to put my hand up now
saying i was able to before
i will okay could i ask you which way
you wish to indicate
council western i'm in i'm in favor
chairman all right
i have that as 12. if you'd like to drop
your hands please members
thank you those members against
saying on and abstain please
that's just the one that makes a total
of
uh 12 4 not against one abstention
that item is carried thank you very much
item seven just give
me a moment please to get that one up
item seven
land between windermere avenue and lower
road
malian lane home bridge although
uh the precise site we will have
explained to us further
by mr strengths who's presenting on this
one thank you
thank you chairman um this application
as the chairman said although
not involving development for 500 homes
at the settlement extension of holbridge
under the
allocations that's currently in progress
in actual fact relates to the roundabout
uh junction between
rorith lane and holbridge road which
we'll come to if we could just jump
to two plan um katie just
to give members a feel for the
development that's currently in progress
members will have seen the
estate road coming in from the south of
the site and the roundabout junction on
to
um onto lower road
if we could now jump to three plan
please
the scheme that you saw there
on uh on the first on the second plan
required mitigation to the roundabout at
the junction of hambro parade shown on
the screen
before you and although it's
hypothetical it's worth explaining to
members that
all what was required to mitigate those
500 dwellings
was junction improvements here shown in
grey that actually just
widen uh rorith lane to
have two approach lanes from the west
coming down roars lane onto the
roundabout
and two lanes on approach from the east
from hamburg hill
uh taking off that like wide uh pavement
area and providing a new uh
uh barrier just in the edged in the
brown there
but that that didn't happen chairman
that was necessary but that didn't
happen if we can jump to plan four
please during the course of dealing with
the outline application
officers expressed to the applicants the
long-held desire of the council
to have a greater junction improvement
because that route is affected
by uh through traffic that uses the
district to get to say shubri
and areas of south end as well as other
parts of the rochford district
and the applicants were able to
negotiate with the landowner
the acquisition of land in the corner of
a field
that we'll see in a moment to provide a
bigger
roundabout and that roundabout which is
over and above what is required to
mitigate the development we were just
looking at and it is given planning
permission
is delivered as part of a legal
agreement to the planning consent the
outline planning consent
that delivers the numbers of dwelling
and as well as a number of other
infrastructure provision now that legal
agreement
requires the roundabout to be completed
at the 50th
occupation of the dwelling of the number
of dwellings on the site
um and your members will have seen that
the construction of this roundabout has
already commenced
um i think the initial laying of or
relaying of
statutory undertakers began actually in
september but the more substantial works
have started i think
around about just before christmas and
both sites both the housing site
and this roundabout are have proceeded
now
during lockdown there are various
restrictions in operation
certain teams and numbers of staff
particularly on the smaller roundabout
site can only work
with certain distance parameters so
there are restrictions although
construction has progressed
they have to do it in in a reduced way
that's
not so much the case for the housing
site although that did suffer i believe
a shutdown in the earlier part of the
the pandemic because it's some 50 acres
or so in size
a lot of the ground workers and other
building staff and contractors
they can spread about more more easily
so they can carry on
progressing and members will be aware
that the central government has strongly
uh recommended that the building
industry be allowed to continue with the
provision of needed homes and
infrastructure
and also the benefits of that to the
economy
now this has meant that the uh
synchronization of the two projects has
got
out of uh sync that is not the the fault
necessarily of the applicant that is the
circumstances that were unforeseen at
the time of signing the agreement
uh back in 2017 and that's uh
brought them back to the council to say
or to seek
if they could revise the agreement such
that it would allow 200 dwellings on the
housing site to be completed
before the roundabout is required to be
finished off and handed over to the
county council
now that's not a a a putting back
necessarily the project
it's anticipating some delays due to the
working
restrictions that they may have to
operate particularly if there is a
future
variant that causes further lockdowns
and restrictions
as well as supplier factors that have
affected it
but it also members will recall that a
year or two back there was congestion
when the applicants were putting their
roundabout in
that we've seen to serve the site other
applicants on other sites were doing
other infrastructure
works and there was a tremendous
congestion
situation now if the 200 dwellings
occupation
was was substituted in this particular
development
it would mean that if there were clashes
the uh
applicants could revise their
programming to try and alleviate
um the congestion that might occur and
and therefore allow this route to
be open and to operate
um it was initially expected that the
roundabout would have been delivered
last summer
but due to the pandemic and the
construction et cetera that's that's
been delayed
um the government as i said have
encouraged construction to continue
and the agreement trigger that was
accepted which was very much an industry
standard of 50 dwellings
wasn't anticipated at the time these
problems
would occur back in in 2017
to allow the roundabout to be required
to the new trigger of 200 dwellings
uh occupied officers feel would give
flexibility to the applicant
to continue working under the current
restrictions on both sites
as encouraged by government and would it
allow the applicant as i said to adapt
their working practices should they
encounter other
difficulties officers consider district
officers consider that is entirely
reasonable
and therefore the recommendation
chairman as you see in the report is
that the
paragraph 433 to the agreement be
revised
to the occupation of 200 dwellings as
set out in the officer report
thank you thank you um
we have mr houghton who's going to
speak to us on this one for a maximum of
five minutes uh mr howarton
when you're ready thank you uh chairman
good evening
councillors my name is ray houghton and
i'm the
head of planning for barrett david
wilson easton counties
i'd like if i may to set out our
reasoning behind
the proposed trigger change i i know
many of you would like some comfort on
why the reverse
the revised trigger is proposed we're
not looking to delay
delivering the roundabout in fact as
your officers advised it is already
under construction
um having commenced in september with
the diversion of utilities
having committed to this obligation i'd
like to assure you that we
will also want the completion of the
roundabout
as quickly as is safely practicable
you will call the construction of the
lower road roundabout coincided with
other significant highway works in the
vicinity being carried out at the same
time
this resulted in congestion as many
diversion rates were themselves
subject to road improvement works
residents and businesses
rightly called for more coordination of
subsequent works
the result the watchful developers form
was organized by the district council
and chaired by the county council
highways it is the responsibility of the
county
to coordinate the issuing of road
permits permits
and clearly this needed to be done with
greater strategic direction
with the support of the county we
accelerated the delivery of the
roundabout
and uh in september we still learned to
complete the works and have the new
roundabout operational by the end of
june
due to the pandemic on the lockdown we
in march
had to seize construction on site
including the roundabout
until we were allowed to open again in
june
since then we've operated under
industry-leading strict social business
rules
which limits the number of people able
to work in any one area
the roundabout is more constrained than
the main housing site
where multiple groups of people are able
to work simultaneously across
54 acres also we're able to build
barrett
and david wilson brands simultaneously
which we can do
i mean we can deliver housing twice as
quickly as would a single brand
house builder therefore the the
differential between
the of delivery houses on a large site
when compared to restricted sites
within the live highway has increased
over time
furthermore a recent extension of the
successful help to buy scheme
and next week's hopefully anticipated
extension by the chancellor
of stamp duty initiatives to the end of
june has
fueled demand for the houses
and surprisingly in this context our
latest sales projection figures
anticipate increased activity to the end
of june
with 84 occupations seven more
in july and eight proposed in august
which takes us up to 99 occupations by
the end of august
advised that the highway permit to work
over the school holidays was given by
essex highways to countryside properties
or their works on london road therefore
if we encounter delays
towards the end of june we'd have to
cease works on the roundabout and
restart in september
uh when of course we beat over the 100
dwellings occupation
uh just to to confirm also we anticipate
reaching the 200th occupation
by the end of next february so within
the year
obviously we are committed to compelling
uh to completing the roundabout
as quickly and safely possible in
accordance with the government's
current social business which as you
know are likely to remain in place until
the 21st of june
the trigger proposed is a maximum not a
target
and is there to provide commercial
certainty if for example
materials from the eu continue to be
difficult to source or should a future
variant result in the introduction of
social distancing
i haven't prepared another lockdown the
professional advice of your officers is
to approve the trigger
we submitted the application back in
june 2020
and since since the direct response to
the pandemic
the and local um demand for our homes at
helms park
uh we're now very close to that 50th
occupation just about a minute to go
thank you i have been able to explain
uh the background
um we hope that future occupiers would
be able to continue to take advantage of
the
government's extended help to find
stanford initiatives
which if we stop work in june we'll no
longer be able to provide that
initiative to them
so the brand right has been built and
will be completed as soon as we safely
can
i respectfully ask the committee uh that
you prove the trigger
thank you very much for your time
thank you for that
um i now only go on to the
member debate council ahoy this is in
your
ward i believe so as a visiting member
are you wishing to speak on this one
uh yes thank you chairman please go
ahead
um yes uh i'd like to thank um
mr houghton for for that summary he did
fade in and out a little bit but i did
grasp most of it
and there was some very good
explanations there which weren't within
the report which made it quite
helpful um i have been uncomfortable
about the
200th occupation because obviously the
report states that
it would normally be about 50 properties
a year
being built which i would estimate
therefore would be
200 would be the summer of 2024 rather
than
early next year as stated by mr halton
um
but i'm aware in conversations with mr
house and he did say that they could
well be building a hundred a year
so there are some inconsistencies here
in the reports
i i do have i did start
this with a lot of reservations my
reservations are less now
um and if i were happy to take a
developer at their word i
don't think i would have a problem but
um i'd
this the the 200th of us
i said it could be the summer of 2024 or
it could be
early next year or late late this year
for what mr houston says
um i'd just like to pick up a couple of
points in in the reports that's been
presented about the
the the roundabout at rothload
lane holbridge road junction not really
being necessary
which was the statement i think all
members would agree this is the first
time
ever in the history of our experience in
planning that
something is on the 106 agreement which
is not necessary
we've always been told that everything
on the 106 agreement is necessary
and must be must have
a connection to the site and be needed
um
it's quite clear in the report when this
was originally passed
in 2016 outline planning permission was
um it it states there i've gone back to
the
document and it states that um
enhancements of the junction between
hamburg hill hull bridge road and north
lane
um it says in the form of a
roundabout it says the proposed
development would generate 228 two-way
vehicle movements in the morning period
and 261 two-way vehicle movements in the
evening period
and it states in that report
that it provision of a new roundabout at
the junction of royal flame holbridge
lane it means holby droid obviously um
it says the junction modelling has shown
that traffic generated by development
will impact on the junction assessed
but with the proposed mitigation above
in place the impact will be
be reduced to provide for nil detriment
or in some cases improvement so
the report when we as a committee passed
this said the roundabout
was required so our dispute that report
we have now is
accurate i mean i don't know how we deal
with contradictory reports but i'm going
by the first one
because that's quite detailed um
the the
the issue i therefore have really is is
just on the why we have to wait for 200
and i'm a bit
surprised that the officers have
accepted 200 and haven't accepted
something near 100
which would seem to be
a better figure given the figures even
with mr hounton's given
if this is to be completed by the the
summer
i i think we um are quite impressed by
the way the roundabout is going
it's moving quite well i think if there
were problems
i think that would be the time to come
back
to us for for this so i
i think i would be doubtful about
approving this but this is obviously up
to the committee
that's all i've got to say at the moment
thank you thank you councillor hi
council award
thank you very much chairman um well
as far as i can see it's actually quite
logical i think
the essence of the 200 is merely a
safety net and that's all
i think this is more a regulatory issue
more than anything else the simple fact
is that
this whole development has gone out of
sync
with the actual roundabout it is as
simple as that the fact is
we do need houses it has helped uh in
regards to their housing delivery and
it's very very important
that that is maintained if there comes a
moment
where there's a contravention in the 106
agreement
an enforcement notice will have to be
delivered
immediately and and that is a big
problem
because what that means is that all work
will stop we will not be delivering
housing
until it is this is cleared up now this
is purely a regulatory
issue i i am fully confident
that this roundabout will be completed
during july
i do not think that uh david wilson
have any intention of reneging on their
initial
concept of getting this roundabout done
as quickly as possible
we've seen what they've done they
started well ahead of time
they have worked really hard the problem
is
is simply covid got in the way just got
in the way
and what we've ended up with is just
being out of sync
completely with the delivery of the
housing which has far accelerated
the ability to keep up with the
roundabout and it is as simple as that
we also i want members to bear in mind
we do have a large waiting list not only
within you know our own housing numbers
but also outside of those numbers there
is a huge waiting list of our
own residents needing properties and
this will contribute towards that
chairman it's the housing waiting list
material planning consideration in
relationship okay
thank you councillor councillor ward is
a visiting member
he he's at liberty to almost say what he
wants it's the members well uh
i'll have this uh control yeah um
well as far as i'm concerned uh i do not
really appreciate
mr boy's interruption i didn't interrupt
him in any way
um i i just carry on thank you chairman
um
i i believe that this should be approved
it is merely
a case this is a regulatory point of
orders are allowed the point of order
was real ruled out
and therefore i will not speak again
thank you
thank you very much just finish off
please council award thank you thank you
it is a regulatory issue that we are
actually looking at
we are trying to amend a 106 agreement
it's a legal agreement
i have every confidence that this
roundabout
will be built out within the correct
parameters
it's just a safety net so we don't have
to keep going backwards and forwards
and keep on amending what we're trying
to do now and i think
what uh has actually been done
as far as the development has been
excellent
i i don't think i need to consider you
know talk anymore on this thank you very
much jim
thank you um i've got
four members who've indicated
to uh contribute to the the this
discussion on this item can i just
remind you members before we
we we start we're actually looking at a
fairly
narrow aspect of a planning application
here
it is whether we change the
uh delivery point from 50 to 200.
so there we are we're obviously quite
quite well aware that there are lots of
other
aspects to do with the development but
this is a narrow point
that we're discussing so i would
appreciate it if you could
keep those uh the discussion focused
councilor wilson please
thanks chairman um i i'm confident that
the roundabout will be built
and um i'd like to thank mr hound for
his
comments and it actually uh explains a
lot of what's in the report
the um normally
and i sort of agree with what council of
the world said
is that what's happened here is that a
false measure both for the building
and for the roundabout and
i i wonder about and i would like legal
advice really perhaps mr owen might be
able to provide this
with the section 106 we've tied this to
the building of houses
um but is it possible just to say that
um or just
just but is it possible to say that um
the developer will make best endeavors
to build the round complete the
roundabout
as soon as possible rather than tie it
um strictly to the number of houses that
are built
thank you chairman i i'll take all the
comments and then we'll sum up all the
various questions in one
one hit councillor hawkway please
uh thank you chairman um i don't know if
mr houston or um uh mr strength could uh
let us know as to whether there are any
financial penalties in not meeting
the current requirement uh as as it
stands within the legal agreement
um and whether
um alluring of the uh the figure would
would be an option for the committee as
to whether it thought it might be better
to go for a
lower figure thank you um mr houghton
unfortunately won't be able to
contribute any further
from this point but we will get an
answer there um
cancer stanley please
thank you chairman um on the on the
basis of this
agreement that we've already got of 50
hounds
and then the red about should be should
be completed
um i do think that i mean they're making
wonderful progress on it i'm
only too happy to see the movement that
is going on
uh it is going well uh i can assure
the builders that uh the guys are doing
a grand job
but nevertheless um i'd like to make a
proposal that uh
uh the proposal is for a minimum
of 150 homes before
um this this can be this can be put into
the 106 agreement i think
uh 150 ohms is is a a in between
um i think uh hopefully that the
developer says he'll have that he'll
have the roundabout finished by
um june july time um
they're getting on really fast with it
so it shouldn't be too far away and i
think
uh to give them a little bit of leeway
would be a good idea of 150 ohms that's
my proposal please
cancel stanley um i will i will sort of
in to
there i believe that the application
that we have is clear in its in 200
and your your your suggestion
is a substantive change to the
application
and i i feel that um
that wouldn't be appropriate i will just
get this question cleared up at this
point
um we obviously not not at a point to
discuss this with the applicant so mr
stranks
um can you comment on that just briefly
um
if if um subject to the advice you get
uh
if if uh if the advice is that it's
appropriate then i'll be prepared to
second uh
let's go let's get the advice first
please thanks
very quickly chairman thank you it would
be appropriate the whole
background to this application is to to
build in some sort of resilience
to the unexpected so whilst thought has
been given to the provision of 200
units the the applicant to address an
earlier question raised
they need a specific time to operate so
whilst
we could talk about best endeavors and
perhaps i'll leave that to mr irwin
it's more useful to have when have we
got to do it
when's the the time scale and if they've
got an occupation of the number of
dwellings you can
you can see that you can prove that yeah
so
this application is framed on the basis
of expecting 200
and you you heard from mr houghton i
think he said well they might hit that
target
in the new year but if members are
uncomfortable with that and
are looking at a lesser figure of 150
given uh you know that that compromise i
don't see that's inappropriate at all
the whole idea of this this proposal is
to build in the resilience as i said and
the flexibility they might need
looking ahead at the difficulties they
can't foresee but may well encounter
thank you councillor stanley we can move
forward
with the proposal that you have
made to amend the motion to 150
rather than 200. do you have a seconder
for that
councillor hookway you'd indicated yes
chairman i'd like to second that
thank you members we're now going to
move
move continuing with the discussion but
we are specifically now talking about
the amended motion of
a change from 50 to 150
um councillor wilkinson
thank you sure um i'm glad that uh my
colleagues said that before me because i
was going to suggest the same
um i like the other councils
have complete faith in the the developer
and i've seen the
folks works going on that's going really
well um
if i understood correctly you anticipate
the
rounds about to be finished by july at
some points and
i think the figure 89 uh occupancies was
mentioned late summer
so um if all things all things being
equal
uh you should have the roundabout finish
with about 70 odd
occupations um so i
i was feeling a bit uncomfortable with
the 200 as well so i'm glad that council
stanley brought forward a lower figure
and that's not to be inappropriately put
inappropriate pressure on the developer
at all i just feel a little bit more
comfortable with it
personally and i will support this
amended motion chairman thank you
thank you very much councillor weston
thank you chairman yes i've been
listening to school i
think uh the um reducing 150 my only
concern is i'm not sure how much
difference it would make i just want you
to have
just wanted to be reiterated of the time
frame of the roundabout
because i didn't want to come back again
and the time frame would change
can we have a definite time frame that
the roundabout will be completed i know
you're talking about july
but it's just going to be a definite
time frame or are we
looking at longer if something else
happens
thank you chairman thank you councillor
fd
thank you chairman um i'm
understanding from what we've said
before that this has a lot to do with
licenses
from essex county council and be able to
do construction on roundabouts
and if i can understand he said these
license might run out in
june time where they'd have to stop
construction on the roundabout but still
build the houses so i think this is
probably why he's put 200 houses on
there
and me not being a developer i'm sure he
knows
what if things go wrong he's got a
give himself a margin of 200 houses so i
s but
i can't support 150. i'm much more
comfortable with the 200 thank you
councillor williams
yeah thank you chairman um i would be
happy to support the 200.
i would also be happy to support 150 but
i would much rather
give the developers a bit more leeway
and make it 200
personally but i will support either
most of the other counselors will
support
thank you thank you mr strangs if you
could just um
do your best to answer the question on
time frame and there was an earlier
question with regard to finance
penalties
i think you'd already made a comment on
best endeavors
thanks chairman um i'm not aware mr owen
may have the advantage of me but i'm not
aware of any formal
financial penalty penalties where where
the the penalties would be
in the supply of housing uh on the other
side
they'd have to stop building whilst they
finished the roundabout
um
the the time frame chairman um i'm not
aware of a strict time
frame in terms of the planning
permission that's left to our colleagues
in the county highway authority and the
developers but i
believe i was right in hearing that mr
houghton
um say that they anticipate
if all things stay equal and there's no
more like interference with
circumstances beyond their control
they would be looking to finish june
july time which i think members are
clear on
the whole the whole purpose of this
exercise this
issue brought before you is that
that the developer can't see ahead
with with clarity that they don't
suddenly find that we're in
contrary to everything another lockdown
or there may be some issues as mr
houghton said with the supply of
materials and so forth
that means that they can't
complete the site a complete roundabout
without it interfering with the progress
of the housing on the site
and in terms of the point i think was
made about licenses
there are other developments going on
and what could happen
is that lots of road works would all be
clashing now
these developers i think are acting with
some responsibility to feel that if they
had the slack
to be able to spot a congestion
occurring they could pull off the works
on
their roundabout to improve traffic flow
for the wider area whereas if they're
forced to
operate to 50 then like all the others
they're going to bang on and get that
site completed
and there would be the congestion
experience so that the greater the
number
the greater the flexibility that's given
to the operators but if they have no
more constraints
they're hoping that it would all be uh
completed
in june july uh this year but they're
hesitant
because you know how can you see ahead
with any any guarantees there is hope
but what if there are other variants
that come through and and
say that the the vaccine may not deal
with
appropriately we go into a lockdown
situation they're trying to manage that
by finding that they could continue to
work under restrictions
unless they're forced to close they
could continue to work on the
on the housing side and the government
would generally say
these flexibilities would still pump the
economy
keep people from work keep housing being
provided so
that the greater the number the greater
flexibility you give the applicant to
plan
if that's helpful chairman okay thank
you uh mr irwin can you just confirm if
there would be financial penalties or
not
yeah thanks chad um i would agree with
mr strength on that point that there
wouldn't be financial penalties it would
be the section 106 would be enforced in
a different way
okay thank you members there's a
recommendation for approval printed on
7.1 in four points
but with the specific amendment put
forward by
councillor stanley and seconded by
councillor hookway
to change the number of 200 to 150
before we go to any voting can i just
ensure that all members have
been properly able to hear and follow
the discussion
all right thank you very much can i
ask if there to indicate with the raised
hand
if any members wish to have a recorded
vote
just see the one so there won't be a
recorded vote on that
you could just drop the hand cancer
stanley please
thank you can i ask those members in
favor
of the amended uh motion for approval
principle feature being 150 to indicate
with the raised hand
one two three
final count one two three four five six
thank you okay those against
uh so drop your hands first please oop
drop the hands let's clear the table
thank you those members against please
indicate
that's five excuse me chairman
if you just drop your hands there please
may i speak chairman not not at the
moment at the moment
okay he's never double we seem to have a
double amount
i think mr councillor williams voted for
and then voted against
no i didn't thank you very much the
officer the officers will
will advise that this is happening
properly did you just drop your hand
please counselor butcher
thank you is there any members wishing
to have oh council butcher
are there any members wishing to abstain
thank you that's eight five
that motion is uh
approved right then
that there are no um items referred
from the weekly list
so at 8 23
i think i can say thank you very much
for your attendance
and contributions and i'll close the
meeting thank you
thank you good night good night thank
you